[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hi wide camera alright
close-up what's going on yeah you guys
can watch this to be nice if you go to
youtube and subscribe you know hey I
don't want to ask for too much how are
ya
how's everybody doing I feel like I said
that a lot but what else you gonna say
like alright let me just get into it I
guess I could just get into it you know
I was thinking I you know anxiety kind
of creeps in we talked about that and
the busier I am I wrote this down in my
journal today because it's just so true
why don't I just keep like reading
saying this to myself the busier you
stay the less time you have to think
about the future so the more time you
have to dwell and go oh my gosh what's
tomorrow gonna bring you you're digging
a hole man but you don't stop digging it
don't that's what we do we just keep
digging it man
but yeah I feel like you know I
definitely staying on the routine for
the most part trying to work out here
trying to you know walking the dogs
dealing with my patreon it's a lot of
work and you know Ryan's not here
obviously across from me but the
episodes I hope you're diggin I'm loving
them I really am in fact there's some
great ones coming up in the future so I
hope you listen to those and all the
other ones that you may not know the
actor or singer or whatever Andrew
Santino was fantastic and maybe a lot of
you didn't know him if you haven't maybe
should go back and listen because he's a
good guest and before that was mental
health week and we had dr. drew on
before that so I kind of threw out some
things to maybe help you guys out there
and help myself
old therapists of mine and the response
was overwhelming so I hope you take the
time all of you boy would that be nice
to just subscribe and write a review
follow us on Instagram and Twitter I
think it's at inside of your podcast or
at inside of your pod anywhere you're at
we had inside of you online store a lot
of great stuff and you shirts
sweatshirts patreon is amazing I love my
my patrons they're so supportive and
loving
and I did a staged it last week and Rob
Danson and I played a bunch of covers
and originals and had a blast so you
want to look out for the next one be on
the lookout on my Instagram or Twitter
and you know they're doing like group
zooms with me and Tom Welling and
Kristin Kreuk and you can get a zoom
with us and things like that so it's all
part of I mean this is a galaxy con is
working something out and then there's
informa that I'm working something out
they haven't announced it I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm telling you right now [ __ ] it
it's gonna be happening soon I think
July 12th is the first one the other
patreon with Jon Heder Napoleon Dynamite
my good buddy we love horror movies as
I've told you it's called where have all
the good horror movies gone and we just
got sure it's available and it's it's so
much fun some tears have a zoom with us
and we talk about movies which ones
we're gonna watch we have a rating
system it's hilarious
people are really digging it and I
appreciate all the support it's a lot of
fun oh so you could write fan mail just
know it could take a long time because I
it's hard for me to get to so it could
take a month two months couple months
down the road and I you know I usually
check it once you know every once in a
while and I have someone who helps me
but it's I'm not getting much help here
but just go to hello at inside of you
podcast calm before we get into our
guest who's unbelievable and if you're
here for tom cavanagh god bless you hey
he's fantastic such a big heart so much
to say so self-deprecating and sweet and
you know from the flash and Edie and
great guy but before we do that why
don't we get an intro to one of his cast
members on flash and that's danielle
Panabaker all right I'm good I'm well I
was thinking about you you got a new
baby how old's the little baby now is it
difficult are you gonna say it's easy
but it's not you know you know we had
our child in the time of coltd which is
scary and you know not the world we
thought we'd bring this baby into but
you know and also none of our friends or
family have been able to meet the baby
so that's been challenging but the
flipside is is my husband's home he's
working from home right now and so he's
been able to spend more time than
right I mean it was the end of the
season anyway for the flash right kind
of I finished my work on the flash
ironically my last episode was season 90
or my last episode was episode 19 they
were supposed to film three more
episodes but they didn't finish them
because production got shut down so
coincidentally my last episode was also
the last episode of flash season six all
right so Tom Cavanagh he's on the show
today I've only heard great things I've
seen in articles that you've said where
it's like he's been through the trenches
with me and he's just like he's seen me
at my worst and he's just like he really
is a I mean just he's so easy to you
know easy to talk to his name he's like
I don't to say he's our father figure on
set but like he's our team captain I
feel like everybody goes to him when
they have issues and like how do what
should we doing about this he's got as
I'm sure you'll see an unbelievable
amount of energy and I truly don't know
where it all comes from yeah I usually
envy those people like how do they have
so much energy
how do they do it do you ever wonder
like gosh I wish I had that much energy
I do wonder I asked him for kids
I'm sure keep him very busy as well he's
just really impressive cool well you
know I just wanted to see how you're
doing I know you had the baby I know
you've been like it's you know some
don't ever let your anybody say children
of the quarantine children of the
quarantine you know it was probably
season one it might have been in the
pilot but we were sitting in the cortex
filming a scene and I was asking Tom
about his kids
and he said do you want kids and I sort
of smiled and said someday and here it
is you know season six come to be Wow
it's kind of a blessing in a weird dark
way that you get to spend so much time
with your kid now and the baby and
that's that's weird right we leave
everyone's got to stay home you can't
see anyone don't do anything so you see
the mom hasn't held the baby no isn't
that insane that's insane I mean it's
obviously
that's the sad part that our satellite
you know hasn't been able to intimately
be a part of this yet and obviously you
know we're looking forward to the time
when they can be they will things will
get better they always get better and
you know not to be too Pollyanna but
also thank goodness first Skype and
FaceTime and all those things that have
made it possible
yeah us to communicate yeah it wouldn't
have been that easy if I said hey
Danielle could you just come over for
five minutes for this little thing like
no anyway this was great this is it this
is it I just wanted to well have you
ever seen him flip out he's just too
nice I've never seen Tom flip out no
he's one of those people who you can
tell he's really upset because he gets
very quiet he you know he's I've seen
him get frustrated and disappointed so
he was directing our 100th episode which
was incredible and something unfortunate
happened to him on that episode and I
just he just was really quiet he didn't
he didn't get angry at anyone like he
just was like okay and moved on but when
Tom is silent you know it's pretty good
yeah do you get silent too or do you
just go what the f I will say this last
episode did I directed now directed
twice unbelievable thanks to Tom and
just getting to see him the way he you
know watching him the first time and he
was so generous with me and so
supportive and you know the second time
I was pregnant and directing and
secretly pregnant and I I lost my temper
once but that's generally not how I am
yeah I can't imagine I figured you get
kind of quiet and just kind of yeah I
think I definitely have like a very
intense meeting voice that like you know
I mean shake does it shake a little bit
it's like alright yeah it's not a
pleasant feeling I don't like being
angry I don't like being angry so
everything else is good that you're home
you're being healthy you're your respect
to the quarantine and and that's that's
that
oh yeah we're super crazy about
quarantine here obviously with a newborn
home so you know very we take everything
really seriously and then you know it's
a sort of a waiting game of I'm lucky to
know that I will have a job to go back
to and it's just kind of waiting until
it's safe to go back I am looking
forward to going to Vancouver though
because it's you know it's pretty safe
up there they don't have that many cases
what's your favorite episode finally
with that with season six I mean I like
how you say that because I remember that
too oh I got a great script to direct as
opposed to the mediocre or crowd these
scripts it because like look people to
understand but there are a lot I mean if
you're writing 22 episodes a year you're
gonna have probably five or six great
ones probably five or six pretty good
ones and the rest fall into the okay -
crap carrot category it's true but we're
doing the best we can like 20 we used to
have 23 episodes a season you know and
you're still sort of confined you only
have so much money and you know you have
some of the bigger more spectacle
episodes where there's really a lot of
money and a ton of special effects spent
and then sometimes you don't spend as
much fun you've got a simpler script
awesome well I think you're amazing and
I love talking to you and I can't wait
to meet the baby so someday yeah I can't
wait it will be alright take care of
yourself give love to Hayes Rutherford B
do you know who that was yes of course
mr. president
yeah we look for presidents names to
name our child
Hannah Baker Robbins no it's rather fun
I'm glad you can go with Rutherford all
right thanks
thank you Sarah talk to you soon she's
honestly so sweet sometimes you look at
people and you're like how can they
possibly be that nice
and you're thinking maybe at home maybe
she gets really upset I don't think so
I'm a good judge of character I think I
don't know
I got fan a letter to read at the end of
this show I'm gonna mention all my
patrons at the end camp Rosie which is
scheduled for October or 31st which is
my summer camp I don't know yet so hang
out and we'll see what happens also
inside of you podcasts live podcast with
Zack Lee by scheduled for July 2nd in
Austin Texas at the North door that's
going to be rescheduled
obviously with what's going on so be on
the look at it will happen hopefully
later in the year but why don't we just
get right into it also we have one of
Tom's old cast mates from the show Edie
and one of his best friends who might
say a word so you might want to listen
to this
let's get inside Tom Cavanaugh it's my
part of you you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know here's the thing I was a little
nervous interviewing you that well
before and the reason is because I think
I feel like when I when I interview
somebody who I know has it together
hang on you know I look at you and
you're like yeah I hear all these great
things about you I talked to Daniel
Panabaker she did an intro on the show
and talked about you and it's like you
know he's just a great guy she talks
about like you know when she's in the
trenches and your guys are there and
you're getting your hands dirty and
she's emotional and listen he she she
says you've seen her at her worst and
you're just the best to be around and
then but and then you see you get four
kids and you're married of stability you
just they don't likable got my god why
couldn't I be that I always compare
myself to people who have their [ __ ]
together
sure listen it's a funny thing right
I'll tell you a quick story about that
because it's always resonated me from
the time I was like in high school I was
walking with my dad and I was like I was
talking about to him about I was like
getting toward being a senior in high
school and I was like hey dad you know
when I was starting out and I was a
freshman those seniors seemed like men
they seemed like they had ever been in
together and they knew the world and
they just knew how to navigate stuff and
they were smart and they were funny and
they had unwritten languages and they
just just seemed like men they seemed
like they had their stuff together and
said now I'm getting there and I still
feel like the freshman I still feel like
I haven't learned a single thing and I
feel like it's just an act and I don't
have my stuff together my dad we were
walking down her sleazy street and he
was a Dean of a college we were walking
down the levy Street toward the college
and he stopped and he was like oh
I've been waiting for that feeling for
my whole life all the professors at the
college just seem to know what they're
doing but I don't feel that way and I
feel like I'm faking it and you know I
was like a young teenager and that just
stuck with me and I so that's the answer
to your questions if you have it every
way more than I do or anybody else you
don't listen to the show obviously
because I don't have it together I'm
constantly trying to gather the others
there's that scene in a Christmas man
cake is to go like here's my flaws right
yeah you know you can step right then
you're just you're never gonna you're
never ever gonna have it together right
part of the whole thing is till I go
okay well I don't have it together those
guys seem like seniors yeah you know
Christmas vacation there's that scene
with Clark Griswold and his dad and he
sits there and the whole house is a mess
and it's just f'd you know when he goes
dad how did you do it how did you do all
those Christmases and all that he says
well I had a little help from Jack
Daniels and that just kind of sums it up
for you now you think dad's got it
together I met you I don't know if you
remember this but I don't have you in
the back yard of Michael Ian Black his
house I mean we cross paths a uni is you
know we're ancient dudes who you know
who are still employable you know a
variety of solid reasons I want to know
those reasons go get back and you'll get
back to the reasons but keep going but
part of that thing is if you there's not
so many people like that if you're
fortunate enough to have that kind of
thing that's just don't worry and then
you
faster those guys you know you like when
you you're like oh I remember the
backyard I remember the bocce I'm in the
Linehan Drive I remember all this stuff
it's like yeah sure that's yeah he's
great I know what's funny is we we spent
probably log together personally side by
each maybe like an hour right great
right that's sort of how Hollywood is in
a way but like I think when you meet
people like you're like you remember if
they were nice if you like them or you
remember if you didn't right you
remember those people I'm sure there's
people in your life that you go whether
you've worked with them or not you've
gone yeah that guy sure even if you
didn't know him that well it's that guy
how do you deal with that guy like in
your and your being on the flash being
on you know when you're right yeah
you've done so much [ __ ] Broadway and
all that stuff when you deal with
personality differences when you just
meet somebody do you is is it is it
difficult to sort of be cordial and fun
and nice cuz you're that guy or do you
sometimes have to do you ever flip out
on some your show is like you know your
your questions there's a preset that
it's like you're going to you're going
to have like self-knowledge any grant
came on your thing and you know I
thought I thought that was a great
episode right I think it was ended with
a lot of people that know him or those
people that don't know him they're gonna
like go hey grant is you know like an
idol of mine or grant is you know the
the greatest thing and he you know he
talks about you know social anxiety and
that kind of stuff and it's like that
there's a
the common thread through all that is
self-knowledge you know and so that
specific question I'm like I could I
could give you an answer and you're like
this is what I do Michael I do this when
I make that guy write one largely I
think the first thing I goes like to
read and react Jenna mean like in I do
and then when you're forced here's a
perfect example if I don't have to spend
time with that guy I'm not going to
spend time with that guy right right and
I'm not going to say listen the reason
I'm not spending time with you is
because I do not like you you do not
have a sunny countenance you're
indulgent right and I won't do that
I'll just I'll go hang out with you you
know and we'll just go have our time
unless I'm forced into you know being
with that person because it's a weird
way or you know yeah that's what I'm
sort of getting that it's like you know
when you work with someone cuz you're
always mr. nice guy you're always the
guy that the leader I mean look at you
the at they that you directed the
hundredth episode of flash they gotta
love you and know that you're you're
stable and you could do the [ __ ] so
that's why that so a guy like you
I wonder that's why the question was
sometimes it comes out weird but the
thought was good guy got a [ __ ] together
on set everybody respects him is there
ever that moment where he's just like
he's just like dude shut the [ __ ] up
well you know we all have those flaws my
experience has been largely when the
guy's a dick there's some there's some
way to work it through and usually that
way is like look I'm just telling you
guy to guy person to person you know if
it's a female if it's a male it doesn't
really it's not a gender specific things
like here's how I feel that's the bottom
line
for me and like Danielle grant can tell
these things like if you shave I think
this this is how I feel no one can say
no you don't you know and I say I feel
like we're not getting along I feel like
you're you don't like me and I'm having
trouble with this kind
I feel this way oftentimes largely my
experience has been there's a way
there's some way in some way to connect
with is the first is the dick just a
dick it's like the time when you're like
you've worked 16 hours and you know
someone's like someone yells out hey
relax or whatever and you just don't
have time for it yeah he's just like
he's waiting me off right those things
you're not like you're not a dick and
there's one of those things where you're
like I got it well there's a way in to
connect a little bit when you when you
have to has been my experience you know
yeah the person is just simply a dick
there's Jenni it's easy to fool them
right huh
you can like say here's what I need this
is gonna be great you're gonna be
amazing you know ah yeah deal Jedi
mind-trick Gill hey you're so awesome oh
my god know it well right there's like
there there seems to be the way in right
is never like they're just gonna go in
oh you're bad you just agree with me
you're bad but like ya know like there's
reason and complements and there's you
know there's there's ways in that's
that's human yeah it's all in security -
I think I think it stems from insecurity
when somebody's for instance when I did
Smallville the first the pilot episode
the guy plays my dad Tony award-winning
John Glover I thought he just didn't
like me I thought I was like wow he he
doesn't like me this is so uncomfortable
I want to I want him I want him to like
me I've always been the guy one I want
you to like me what can I do to make you
like me the one guy in the room that
doesn't like me maybe - I want them to
like me
and then so at the end I just said it
wasn't until the series got picked up I
started talking and I'm like yeah I just
uh you did not like me in the pilot hi
cuz what I go I just felt like he didn't
like me he's like ah of course I was so
nervous they had called me two days
before to do this and I I'm doing my
John Glover impression and you know and
that was sort of the way it was by the
way you do you do impressions and when I
saw this interview with you that I loved
because it's so true and
really actors get it but you really gave
some perspective to the outside world
looking in like those guys like
Christian Bale when they do Batman when
they play superheroes when they talk a
certain way it's so true cuz I'm like I
always think I got to play Lex cooler
than this I can't be Rosenbaum no well
that's Rosa Mama's Lex Luthor I can't be
late
hey Clark do you we should go [ __ ] I
don't know drive in my Porsche who says
Porsche and then so there was sort of
like a reserved kind of thing that I
wasn't used to doing that I got used to
doing it wasn't that I completely went
okay Tom that's a word but you have to
tell me about that tell the audience who
hasn't heard that that fear you have
part of it was like the conditions of
being because you know you and I both
play iconic you know there was like a
when I play I play the reverse-flash for
for the people who don't know on the
show which is like that's an archenemy
of the flash and flash is played
winningly by Grant Gustin and the
reverse flash is played service of Lee
buddy by Tom Cavanaugh and you know
their archenemies they're the
reverse-flash is the the Joker to the
flash is Batman and when you're playing
like one of those archenemies you know
there's a there's a catalog of this is
how we do it as part of the pantheon and
the thing that I used to come into is
the debacle of ten yards versus forty
yards because if he's here down the
street and I'm like you know to catch me
alive Michael you know I I do the super
cool thing to remember this is an aside
you're gonna love this there was a time
in the late 90s early arts when when
they were doing Michael Rosenbaum and
you were on a NBC right and they were
doing a promo for you they wanted even
really did all those promo they wanted
you and your co-star when they were
doing your solo they wanted you to do
this ready and action
you remember that yeah I'm a fluid downs
then even say Bill hello it bled out
from the entertainment industry into
sports so that drew brees quarterback
for the New Orleans Saints and they'd be
like he'd never believe you later
I remember watching oh like Eli Manning
and all these guys just be like when
they let me read their number they just
kind of looking up right and it's sort
of it's still there but it used to be an
85 percent barometer now it's kind of
comes in around 30 but there was that
thing where they also like they did this
too when it was you know when you were
like you would like just kind of swing
back and forth oh yeah I felt so stupid
doing these promos and then you kind of
would do this like oh I'm sitting on a
chair a spinning chair spinning around
yeah kind of looking when you're and so
for these kind of stereotypical moments
to break out of it's very difficult as
you know to break out of them because
this is how it's done in the comic book
right right
really is the guy you know like who's
just like completely you know what
you're not be for me even from 40 feet
away but you think but no because you
did this whole thing or you're like you
someone's yelling and you're like or if
it was you and I facing off I'd be like
I planned bang and then you'd be later
on I'll never you want some fries you'll
never take me alive
Michael I well you need a ride or a
cycle I'm so sorry
never mind never mind the guy that was
doing unrolling filming he was basically
ordering sushi
he was already included in a restaurant
I'm sorry you have that you all just
have water but it's cold if that's the
cool voice and when you're far away I
don't
many times I've said that where I'm
talking to you know you're right Clark
across the room and he's like and I'm
just like no I'm not cool when they air
this it won't be cool it'll be cool now
and how many times have you seen I've
had guest stars come on and they're even
quieter than anybody I've ever heard and
I'm talking and I'm like I need you to
check up on this scientist I want you to
check him I was like sir we haven't
found any information but what I can't
hear what you're saying and he kept
doing it oh my god [ __ ] this guy's gonna
be terrible and then you see not God
that guy was great so intense I got to
do the lower register voice yeah I mean
cuz look it look Broadway doing a lot of
theater you did ad you've done movies
and now you're on flash and now you get
to play a bad guy and then you get to
play a bunch of other characters you
look dr. wells
who's like different personalities
raised all over the places in different
universes this character so you could
play sort of nice and sort of like you
just you like this stuff as much as you
like the Broadway as much as you like
the straight drama or is it just another
thing that you're you're experiencing in
comparison in any way only because
that's this is not a politically correct
answer and I think you understand why
this is because I I proceeded from
gratitude to have any job I really knew
yeah it's not like that is not like a
blanket statement of like you know
because one of the things that
especially I think you and I know this
and I think it's it's lost on people
that have success at 21 and they'll
don't they'll get there because how
could you have any basis of comparison
but the idea that you know proceeding
from gratitude for the employment or the
or the specific job that you have is a
huge thing because I think a lot of
people go well Michael it's just he's
just dancing from this show to that show
to this movie to that play to this kind
of thing and Tom's doing the same and I
think what people miss is the giant and
capitalized letters
they have you and most of the time they
want they want somebody better than me
they want somebody as is more of cachet
they want they want Brad Pitt they want
the and that's a that's a that's kind of
fanciful fanciful example you know it's
like if that's the way it is that's just
a way Hollywood if they're if they can
get me they're also kinda like well
maybe we could get Matthew Perry or like
there's there's some other element
that's kind of close but you know like
it's a better gift for them it's a
better splash when they make an
announcement and we weren't into that
all the time and I think when I watch
somebody who's not me like you and he's
just going from keep the gate or I look
at you know movie stars I look at I'm
friends with this isn't this is a name
drop but he's doing such great stuff
right now John Krasinski oh dude by the
way I'm a huge horror fan I'm yeah huge
and quiet place was just one of the
things that I really liked I mean I
don't like a lot of horror these days
and that was really good pull things one
of the main things I try to do is and
it's obvious because every director I
think wants to do this but you want to
show and not to tell but that movie the
whole the whole basis of that movie was
show don't tell because they're not
can't talk right and so it's so
interesting right like oftentimes when
you're young acted like can you
communicate what you're trying what's
going on in the scene without using
words and you should be able to do that
by and large but then of course we do
superhero shows where there's a massive
amount of writing about feelings
people are so so there's so much
self-knowledge you run into something
like a quiet place it can be jarring
because they did such a magnificent job
you these characters were so rich and so
old fulfilled and yet I would have died
I would have died in the first minute
not being able to say anything even if I
wasn't supposed to die I still would
have died
Rosenbaum you can't talk why I just
so I know he survives to page 68 we
would think and get rid of him what if
we killed Michael mad at the first scene
would that be cool like I know it's a
rewrite but we could do that
plus the other actors can't hear him
when they're acting he's like far away
he's not even he's whispering like he's
playing a superhero or something I just
[Music]
I don't have I know it seems Pat but it
really is true I never would have
expected you know to be putting on in
the age of superhero to be one of the
people who gets to put on the villain
suit you know what I mean that would
never have been you know when I started
out professionally never thought at one
point you know I hope to play Joker or
you know reverse-flash or something like
that and so I have a massive amount of
gratitude for that because you know that
could have gone to a myriad of humans
and I you know that became one of those
things like will they have you would
have me for that one and so I think for
most of the rules that you get you're
just like oh that's great I got that I
got control I remember my first Broadway
show I got cotton Canadian I got cast
out of Canada I couldn't believe it I
just I couldn't believe it you know the
Urinetown it was a pleasure no that was
a play it was around the turn our boys
coming home from war like it was you
know human a national nightmare was over
and maybe that was so she'll called
shenandoah about that about the Civil
War musical starring Hal Linden from
Barney Miller fame went on to went onto
the voice by the inimitable John Coulomb
interesting enough John Coleman died I
did another Broadway show years later
and John Cohen who's the lead of that
one too you know he's a massive talent
and you know the interesting thing is
about about that is when the New York
the Broadway producers came to came
under search through America and then
through
you know they the advantage I had was
they didn't know anybody so in the
echelon of Canadian actors I was at the
very bottom but they didn't know who the
guys at the top were either so his brief
moment in the audition room was a fair
fight and you know I got that I got that
job and the gratitude for getting that
job going to Broadway you know you they
had the elation when they're like hey
guess what Michael you're you got that
you got to roll and it's like it lasts
for a little bit and then you get there
and then there's obstacles to overcome
and you're like this guy's an idiot and
you know something doesn't go well and
you're like it all plunges away like I
remember playing basketball and I just
want to make the team and then after you
may continue that's all you wanted you
just want to be part of the team after
why was it play and that's when I
started to get my point you know like
it's like if you have a competitive
nature or what is interesting about that
Broadway thing and I know I'm talking
about myself no I want you to the
interesting thing about that Broadway
thing is that elation lasted it's still
there I mean knowing that stuff goes
away and then you like start taking
stuff for granted walking down from 72nd
Street where I live down to like the
theater I'd be like this is ridiculous
you just kept waiting for someone girl
like okay right you just at the stage
door moment you know you really felt
like so do you feel like that even today
or is that kind of that feeling that you
don't feel that anymore is it more like
a job do you still get excited you still
get excited about going on on the set of
the flash do you or does it become just
kind of like work because it is a lot of
work I mean a lot of people say no no I
go I have fun every day but the reality
is do you I mean is it that say and I
think a lot of things yeah I think I
think I'm aware that they say nice
things and I'm aware that you know
harder says are you wearing a C which is
like for a captain and that's largely
because for people like you you've been
through enough that you've seen enough
situations you can you can't offer
advice on this thing because you've seen
it before and that thing and so
the short answer to the question is yeah
that's still there and the reason one of
the main reasons that's that's there is
because when you don't job hop from job
to job to job you have these valleys and
people don't see it and then it's like
hey George Clooney hasn't worked for two
years but you don't know that because
he's George Clooney and you don't know
what kind of things he's been through
and it's the same thing for every actor
it's like oh now you're doing flash so
that's great but what they don't know is
that you had these valleys between where
you're like I got to make my rent
I got a few family you know and those
things the more the longer your careers
the more you run into those those
valleys and every actor is going to run
into those those things because even for
the huge movie stars I read this thing
that again to talk about which I don't
know Clooney I'm just I'm just they all
know Clooney said he thought the heat
was the ER P Diddy yard he was like you
know he came at this huge movie star and
he you know he just gradually became the
biggest thing and he said in an
interview which I think he should have
interviewed Julia Roberts who also is a
mega mega star and his point was he
thought that when he made it then there
was a golden domed room of gilded
scripts and once he became a movie star
those would all be you know plenty it's
would open right would be for him he
could just pick and choose and then when
you realize when what he realized was
that well Leo wants it and Brad wants it
and everybody had wants it and so and
then they don't audition anymore and so
that becomes a bit of a political game
and there aren't that many really really
good scripts around and so even for
those people at what we consider to be
the height of stardom they have their
own anxieties and they had their own
Khurram if everyone thought on on a Fox
series with Kevin Bacon and he and I
sort of lived in the same neighborhood
in New York and it was quite it was
great to see him and then he's Kevin
Bacon and one time as an aside you know
we were just kind of sitting talking
while they're setting up a shot and
you're talking about his career and the
thing that resonated with me said yes
kind of waiting for the other shoe to
drop you know meaning you know that
there's more stuff coming hopefully you
know what I mean and then he's really
gonna you know it's right learning it
weathers to me it's like that is the
kind of career that I aspired to the
every actor aspires to all these iconic
movies and these great performances you
know and plays music and he's just an
involved guy and you're kind of like
that guy is waiting and I need to be
grateful for what of course
well you said hang on you said I want to
go back a little bit because you said
something about those moments where you
just want to get your rent and you those
meals and this and that you probably had
them pre ed pre-med pre ed right you
probably had those films did you have
any of those after ed lasted four years
and were there any of those times where
you were like oh I got to get back to
work I got a I mean especially when you
have a family I guess that's a dumb
question really because you always have
to kind of work when yet if four kids
always like you're focused on the thing
that it's coming and if you've done
anything good
it doesn't matter there's a Billie
Holiday line one thing for always in too
many but twice meaning like you may have
done something but that doesn't that
means nothing you know I mean what's the
big I hate that I hate that what you
just said thin it again once a four
always into ain't no choice but well
here's why it's good here's why okay if
you screw up it's as part of the idea
there'd been a guy who I get who wrote
an article in The New Yorker it was just
a base that they keep in a war hero but
also he pinned he'd done something awful
and the idea behind her is like we're
all gonna screw up and when you screw up
the important thing is to remember that
that doesn't make you a screw-up you
know and if you've done something great
it doesn't make you a great person you
know Babe Ruth had this quote yesterday
make sense
yesterday's homeruns don't win today's
games right and so I think that's that's
a massive part of not only is it I think
a healthy thing to like just to stay
humble but also I think for what we do
if you think yeah I've got it that's
death a little bit you know yeah you
lose your drive maybe you're the guy in
the price you want to be like nobody
cares about what you've done in the past
when you're doing the scene now that
this scene now has to be done well and
you know if you don't if you don't nail
it you feel you feel badly a little bit
and that you know that's a that's an
ongoing challenge is the thing that's
gonna keep you sharp a little bit as
opposed to like complacency which is
which is gonna kill you so yeah I mean I
been Canadian first I didn't have the
advantages of you know for an American
person they can go audition but for a
Canadian person they have to cross over
the border and then they have to like
addition and then have to get it they
have to show the papers and there's a
massive thing to overcome and so part of
the thing just to play at the level that
you're playing at was there's a struggle
to get there so that that's that's a
leap of faith and you once you once you
get that then it's like well I hope I
can keep keep with it and if you get
fortune F to do something like and like
that came after like a decade's worth of
doing musical theater and Canadian
television and what was interesting
about that is nobody knows what you're
doing when you're doing we're not at
least back in the day when I was doing
he's different now but when I was doing
Canadian television series nobody would
watch them they were all watching France
and what was good about that was you you
still did the same daily that you do
that I do when you go to do a television
show now it's still there's there's the
grip sitting there setting up the stuff
there's the there's the juicers there's
electrics there's the you know there's
the camera guys sitting the tractors and
all that stuff right everyone's doing
their job and it's the exact same
regardless of whether somebody watches
it or doesn't watch it and it gets you
into this mindset that this is what
matters this is important to do this he
well so by the time you get something
like a decade later you get
we're not reading reviews we're just
trying to do this thing well and then
when that show ends and you're doing
something else and nobody wants you
anymore you're like the I don't that is
scrambling fight you know I I worked so
I did after end was a show with Jason
Priestley who had been this supernova
star for the younger viewers here for
your show late on 90210 and he'd been as
big as you could get and then after that
people said well you did that guy you
did Brandon now we don't want you and he
just had to like stay humble work hard
he became a really talented and able
director you know he just like I'm gonna
go fight for Rawls and that's what he
said people don't like were happy to
have you and then when he wouldn't go
out walking around to be shot in New
York when we walk around everybody
wanted a piece and he always had time
for people yeah I remember
that's just great it's like Cal Ripken
signing every autograph while he's doing
the street just like like you know you
need to be grateful for what you have
which sounds trickier inside of you is
brought to you by fair harbor don't you
think of fast forwarding fair harbors
clothing is just incredible all my
friends have ordered my friend Rob order
my friend Ethan order my friend Tom both
Tom's ordered it and they're like dude I
gotta tell ya
pretty comfortable you don't even have
to wear underwear with this stuff just
buy it I'm telling you you'll thank me
fair harbor has reinvented the swimsuit
by replacing all mesh lining with their
supersoft built-in boxer-brief that's
the key it's it's it's a great
experience and you know I don't even
wear underwear cuz I'm just wearing
these all the time I have like a whole
drawer full of clean underwear the
world's most comfortable shorts most
versatile from swimming to running to
just hang out I never need to take these
off it's written right there I never
need to take these off but the thing is
I probably should have written that
because I don't take them off all the
fair harbors products are made from
recycled plastic bottles to date fair
harbors recycled over 2.5 million
plastic bottles keeping plastics out of
waterways and off of beaches fair harbor
makes products for you to enjoy the
places you love
protecting those places at the same time
20% off for everyone listening and all
you have to do is head over to fair
harbor clothing calm and use the code
inside 20 and they're gonna give you 20%
off that's inside inside 20 not twice
just inside 20 and say goodbye to mesh
lining forever and chafing fair harbor I
wear them constantly and so should you
I saw a video of you talking about you
at a convention and you're gonna race
your fans and you say why and you sort
of like but I love my fans like people
are like you know I'm a fan if you saw
my room it's just like post your
autographs have tough luck yeah when I
go to cons people don't realize I used
to go to cons before I was anybody I
used to go to horror cons like New
Jersey horror fest or whatever Fright
Fest uh and meet like meet like fly boy
the guy in Dawn of the Dead so and the
guy in the helicopter I'm like oh my god
his autograph ten bucks I gotta go I
gotta go get it signed so when I hear
about this I go there and I really enjoy
my I feel like they're friends they're
like they sort of get it and they know
me that's like I'm finally the cool guy
maybe even though I'm not like High
School's never the cool guy so when I go
there I'm like hey I belong I belong
here with these folks this is cool so do
you feel like I feel like you you're
also a fan in a way but you just like
the way you handle your fans and I think
you seem like you really enjoy it yeah I
know I keep repeating myself as like you
know you're grateful you're fortunate I
feel fortunate to be in the position I
think that it's a I think it's a massive
thing to have like there was this flyboy
back in the day was like a niche thing
and now if you go to San Diego comic-con
you know that's general knowledge and
accepted like it's part of the
mainstream right in a good way it's not
comic books in a bedroom it's like this
is the Golden Age of this thing you know
what I mean and you do stuff where
you're part of that you're part of that
yeah that's what interest that's
incredible to me
a Golden Age of anything I think and
maybe not even maybe the Golden Age
might be like 20 years down who knows
but there's an element to the fact that
you the cons are not for that they're
for the uninformed and the informed
nowadays you know it's just like it -
it's mass entertainment and if you get
to be one of those guys like that you go
into Hall H and everyone's cheering for
you because everybody knows you because
you know you share sort of the same you
share the same ideologies as the people
in the stands and that makes you first
off not cool and cool is a myth right
it's just like great you don't spend any
time doing that you just want to jump in
and enjoy the life that you're given and
that's the part of me that can't be
uncool jump in there yeah and so I you
know it's never lost it like look the
reason like the flash is a popular show
on on CW is because of these people it's
like it's simply really simple right
it's just like yeah and again the
benefit of being on canceled show after
canceled she'll have to cancel Jim their
unity yeah and like I've been on the
show where I was like I was supposed to
go promote the show for its third
episode and I was on this is another
name drop Conan O'Brien and there's a
knock on the door and it's the producer
third episode about to do : to promote
the show and you know it's Michael
router the producer showrunner who's
like hey they pulled us you know what I
mean and you know why that's Hollywood
they're not your friends like well
before we went on to wait a mill or
about to do Conan and they told you this
correct that's how you found out before
you went on-air correct who would tell
you that well I'm glad they told me so I
didn't go promote a show that had been
yanked Hollywood story because
on the surface it just seems so mean
right right
nobody's weather my experience is
nobody's really even then there's
nothing there's no there was vindictive
and I got to get you it's a numbers game
you know let you can help them you know
and or you know you can't help them you
know I mean and it's just like they're
like is is he is Michael gonna be a good
announcement are we happy to have them
like there's a lot of things like oh you
can help us so good so we got to get my
phone or it's like yeah you know we're
not gonna he's not gonna help us right
and so you know one of the best advice
we can give anybody is I don't think it
personally in you know in the
entertainment world it's more than
you're sensitive I'm sensitive you will
take it personally yeah you would be
broken you have to learn you have to
learn how to deal with that yeah of
course you'll be crushed but there's a
difference between having a thing that
you love taken from you you know when I
say a thing you love I mean you know
like your job you know having that taken
from you versus having someone take that
job from you to purposefully hurt you
which is my expresses that they're not
knowing everyone's just these these
executives who are doing that they're
scrambling there's a lot of fear it's
all of what am I gonna do I don't know
what to do I'm listening to you I don't
what are you now honestly now what I
would have probably done it was really
going hey actually I just backstage
heard that the show got cancelled so
there's not a great time so thick I mean
what did you do well you know I was only
there to promote that show and even
though this podcast is gonna make it
seem like I love talking about myself I
don't
I like you're the guest look you know
any times I've heard Tom know each other
oh he was talking over the guest um let
the guests talk I'm like dudes it's an
hour sometimes I do talk over [ __ ] you
know but like you're the guest so they
want you to talk but I talked enough
this podcast will be the end of your
podcast I read that said I couldn't
stand any more
listening to one more actor talk I just
turn them on no this is all that's so
interesting go go so this stuff because
I don't like talking about myself and
because I've done a few television shows
up to that point I had Conan worked for
NBC and I work for NBC and so we cross
past the number of time we lived in the
same neighborhood he's you know uh he's
so very talented he's a I'm sure you
know this and people know this but I was
on Conan before he's so quick yes funny
he's quick he's Harvard educated he's
like he's he's just he's humble he's got
all those incredible things together and
so he understood when I had done his
show before I was like I don't like
talking about me and so he or we would
come up with some kind of gag or some
kind of prank that I pulled on the show
we and he would air it at one point we
did I showed him how to browse like
craft service table that was a segment
that we did ended up with somebody
getting shot but yeah he was like you
want to do comedy let's do comedy but he
was game for that's cool you know I I
yeah go ahead we were doing that thing
and we were going to promote the show
and I'm ready to go and then there's the
knock on the door and I think it's the
segment producer as you know that's the
person who comes in and goes like hey
Michael so remember what you talked
about this this this this this and gonna
walk you out to the stage and there's a
knock on the door and I think it's a
segment producer but it's Michael Roush
the showrunner and Michael go who's
Michael goes so they pulled us I'll
never forget the intonation I'll never
forget the words verbatim he goes so
they pulled us and we stared at each
other were in the green room standing
each other and then he kind of closes
the door but kind of looking each other
and and it's a knock and Lily I'm
supposed to go you know and and this
time it's not the second I'm pretty sure
it's Conan Conan goes
I just heard and I'm like yeah and he
says and this is like at one of those
like action movies works like 30 29 28
and he's like I totally get it if you
don't want to go on but you're a double
and I got nothing else a double means
like we're gonna do a thing we're gonna
commercial break come back I've never
been a double I'm a single and I get out
and I'm like I'm like no I'll go
he's okay good and then they're rushing
us out there and it's like Oh talk about
what just happened I was like better not
I don't know what I would say that might
be really good that he's like yeah yeah
okay and literally he's like dude and
conocer the guys welcome back and he's
like I'm here we talked about
so you bike right the thing just sales
by because he's so funny and he's so
quick and nobody would ever have known
and then that summer I was doing urine
therapy so I can't come back on the show
he's like now can we talk about it
and I'm like yeah now we can talk about
it was the last time Tom was here we two
never hooked he told the story and
people in the audience were oh yeah
because he was like that's Hollywood you
know and yet even though it's like the
most Hollywood kind of bad bad Hollywood
there's knowing intense like I say
there's no intensive evil behind it how
many these seasons did you do that was a
third episode just three episodes in and
what was it called love monkey well I
mean that's just f'd three episodes how
do you know anything well Jeff hear
about Seinfeld you get things a chance
this is the thing though I remember a
friend of mine did a show called like
and two friends they both did shows that
were like on it and love monkey was the
same thing was that every so I live in
New York it was on every bus every
taxicab and it was like they loved it we
shot a full season and as you know but
maybe people who listening don't know
they should we shoot so many episodes
before we ever aired them and so for a
while the only the only barometer you
have is is it good when it lands on your
desk and so you know I think that show
you know that I think that that show we
were fine let me put it this way I think
we were we were finding our way but the
there was something ephemeral about Judy
Greer was in the Constitution Jason
Priestley Chris wheeler in state they
were there was all set there was such
talented human beings in that show that
there was something ephemeral that
translated from that to the screen and
we were finding out how to capture it
and I think the the reaction from the
network was like this is great you know
I think they really did enjoy it you
was an hour long that's trouble one
about an A&R music guy in New York City
so it wasn't blood and semen for your
hour-long you know it wasn't think it
was a link murder it was just like you
know it was it was human drama and I
think that's a big problem on a big
network and again like I say not to
offer excuses but that's an hour of time
and if you can put CSI on and double the
numbers you're probably going to do that
but they were taking a shot we're trying
to make the network a little younger a
little hipper in New York cool that way
and are all that kind of stuff some some
a little bit of sex a little bit of that
kind of stuff and so you can't blame
them for taking the for a to try and be
more competitive with the cool factor
that at the time NBC Fox and those shows
and yeah I get yeah so they were doing
that but then what's interesting is many
reasons why not and then the mike
omalley show it happened just prior to
that and what's interesting is they were
plastered on every bus as well and
you'll probably remember this oh yeah
you were doing stuff they were like the
new big thing yeah and the amount of
money that got sunk into you know the
advertising budget was was astounding
and up until that those moments in my
experience anyway bridging both the you
know the analog-to-digital of all this
kind of stuff there was a there was a
thing where like if you put that much
money into promotion then you had to go
with the show and so famously shows like
cheers and Seinfeld and friends that
didn't perform well but had been
promoted they're like look can't just
yank it off the air why because we'll
look silly and so they gave them enough
time and they had champions Tartikoff
and so on who are like no this thing is
good right I put it on my desk I did the
litmus test the barometer was it showed
up on my desk and it looks good so we're
gonna stay with it for a little bit but
with Michael malady and with Emily's
reasons why not when they didn't perform
numbers wise to what they'd hope they
would get because of promotion they took
them off the air immediately I think it
was a one episode or two episodes at the
time and there was no penalty
there was an old backlash penalty to the
networks and I think that became oh
that's an mo again if we can kick them
off and put on CSI nobody's gonna is not
coming back guys and that's just what
we're going to do well you have a very
cerebral way of thinking about these
things I don't know if you do it
retrospectively of like if we look back
at the younger Tom Cavanagh and go now
he was [ __ ] pissed the girl he was
dating or Lou's wife at the time
whatever was she like oh my god remember
how upset you were you were smoking pot
constantly you were drinking all bunch
of [ __ ] you were you get it and now you
look at you and you're like yeah was it
the same mentality or was there as a
part of that where you're like flipping
out you know ice Popp smoking less
drinking it was a lot more heartbreak
you know it was like that was the thing
mostly it wasn't so much like you
[ __ ] guys it was more like I really
like because you know how it is I really
like acting with you and I'm hoping that
we can do this for a long time yeah and
then it gets you yanked away yeah and
part of the reason that makes it so
special
acting with you is because I know it can
be yanked away man what you hope is that
it won't be yanked away and when it does
get yanked away even though hey we gotta
get together hey we got it that never
happens if you're fortunate you take one
or two people from each show and you
stay with them but you're intense your
intentions are great but everyone else
has to go make a living try and find
another job and go on and and do that
and so there's heartbreak because the
reality is the thing that you love and
the people that you love you're just not
gonna see them anymore and that was
that's the biggest thing the other thing
is and this is the silver lining or the
the golden part of it is like you know
what
that's that door closing is alright what
am I gonna do next yeah what could come
next well you know something that uh
look at the flash I mean for instance I
mean how many years since you came on I
mean you came in six years ago yeah you
you didn't think you were gonna even be
on the series that long right it was
just a like a introduction of a
character did you think you were gonna
be on this long no of course not
it felt like after season one it was
flash versus reverse flash and I thought
that this is just and again I know I'm
talking about myself so much but Greg
Berlanti who's like Hollywood's golden
boy who were producer he's just
tremendous he's one of the great human
beings that I've ever worked with
you know I remember Bill Lawrence
Michael Rosen Rob Burnett these guys are
show runners of shows that I've done and
I've been really fortunate to work with
people who are like great humans like
they're intelligent they're smart that
perspective bill Lawrence is one of the
guys who his little quote was that if
you can't take it personally you know
drugs right here's one crazy here you
know the guy that did live in city in
scrubs and he's like they're not going
to put the show and he's think you can
never take it personally and you pick up
stuff like that and so you know Greg is
is he is so impressive because of his
integrity and I think most people work
on a shows can go like yeah it's rare
that you meet someone who's so committed
to doing the right thing and back a long
time ago you know there was a couple
things I went in for a show of his and
he wanted me for one of the leads and I
didn't do it and I thought well that'll
be it
that'll be it for him and I and he said
well I walked out after saying no and
his words he was like well I'm not going
anywhere
meaning he's gonna be around to do other
shows but I was like that'll be it cuz I
didn't do the show and then a little
while later he did the show called Jack
and Bobby which lasted a season and
called me up and said hey do you want to
play this guy who rages at the ranges at
the moon and felt like a looks like a
drug problem or an alcohol problem and
like he's got more things going on than
that complicated character and wait you
know that was Eli Stone so Jackie Bobby
was a
cocaine-addicted brother to Christine
Lahti and you know at the time people
like he comes a nice guy so but Greg
would kick me for these like challenging
roles and offer that to me and I was
like this is an honor to haven't think
that I could do this and that show only
lasted here and then the next one we got
raging at the moon was Eli Stone again
he called and it's one of those guys who
it's starting to get a call in your
corner everyone needs that guy he's just
always been in your corner he always
sees he sees oh yeah we're so rare yes
that's it that's what you always think
of you if I turned down something or a
flight yeah you're like oh my god I was
I remember I did this pilot am I gonna
say the guy's name but a big director I
did apologies listen if you do this pile
for me I'm gonna put you in all my
movies I want you to do this role and I
ended up doing in the pod and get picked
up in 20 years but then there are other
guys like Eric Tannenbaum who he's a big
producer who produced Two and a Half Men
and you know use with co-creator but he
wanted bane producers on that show but
he sent me the script because hey I want
to I want you to do this and I just was
like yeah just not for me I don't wanna
do that I just really died just didn't
want to do that that role and then I was
like that's it I'll never call back and
then he he did we did a show called him
pastor for two years and he believed me
he's like listen you're this guy you
have to do this and we talked about it
and we did it and so you're right I it's
it is rare when they come back usually
they get it's almost like you get one
shot all that producer hates me now
didn't do the role for them they always
feel that but it's a rare occasion so
that's nice to have somebody like
somebody who's as prolific and committed
as as Greg believed in you is it is
amazing and so when we first started the
flash together obviously it had a
modicum of cachet because they done
arrow and now I've done well but you
just never know and like you expect me
to knock on the thing like hey they
pulled us and Greg Greg I think people
forget and come from that you know Jack
and Bobby when she's like he's done a
lot of things that didn't say this guy
is gonna become the biggest you feel
producer of all time and so and he
stayed humble
and flash very early on you know in my
head we would be canceled by October
because that's just been the experience
like we'll do seven and then seven to 13
yeah and your wife was probably saying
like what do you think you know like
yeah but probably do thats now be it I'm
just that's what I'm counting on right
she was starting a thing called the
players Tribune because she's a creative
director of the players to doing for
your sports fans out there which is that
the Derek Jeter branded site that talks
about the story of the athlete in their
own words and it's tremendous you know
it's where Steve Nash announced his
retirement yeah brian is one of it was
was always on the board there's just a
great it's a great site with integrity
because instead of II W interviewing you
about your story as an actor you read it
out yourself you know and what's that
noise but that's a that's a garbage
truck no it's not what that is it's
essential I think he ain't my toes he
deals like what is it what is that sound
so but because it was a because Jeter
was finishing off his time with the
Yankees and it was a you know digital
startup you know both both of them were
like you know there's four people that
start up like what will be done in like
two months I'll be a and we were
starting to flash I was like well we'll
be done in October that'll be it and
because that's largely the the story and
very early on we had a we had a couple
of things that happened really quickly
we introduced like a some some big names
on the show and I remember saying to
Greg are we all worried about story
because we were just like flopping all
this stuff out and he was like there's
always more story and his his intent was
like look I love the flash and if it
gets cancelled like so many stuff I just
want to have that DVD on my desk which
dates Greg but is they when I have that
DVD on my desk to say I did it
and so season one was various such a
simple and clean thing where flash his
mother was killed by the villain and he
needs to confront the villain and then
just and who is the villain and I was in
a wheelchair and I was a villain but you
didn't really know her then together
layers of the onion got peeled out and
then again there was like flashlights
reverse-flash and the season one and it
was like crisp and clean storytelling
I thought the cast gelled well and did a
good job telling that story and it's
very difficult as you know it's like
well we did it and then it's like oh
wait now they want more and so even
though you know I think a lot of like
producers and writers sound confident
that I've been in that thing where
you're writing something you're like I
don't know I'm I'm on Edie Rob Burnett
said we're bringing your parents in
because in episode 10 just like we got
nothing else
and that's show last four more years the
second time that can be a daunting thing
for people who are trying to tell the
story and so so when did you know when
did a twin thing just that first laughs
I thought like well that's yeah you know
because you can't you can't have him
every four episodes going like you'll
never get me flash right I just can't do
that you can't repeat that you have to
like good storytelling is like you want
to invent some new stuff and so I
thought well that's it for me
but then Greg and I had this idea of
like what if because there's it's in our
thing there's a multiverse which is
there's many different versions of
Michael we thought well what if we could
create a different guy every season and
then as an actor you like and still be
the reverse-flash where we need to be
the doctor heroes channels so it end up
being like you know such an incredible
such an incredible run it's incredible
that kind of thing almost never happens
where you get to like as an actor to
dream to create more than one care if
you're fortunate enough to be on a
long-running show and flashes turned out
to be that then Largent you're playing
the same person to be able to reinvent
you know I also play speaking of which
speaking of which before I got some [ __ ]
talking questions for my patreon and I'm
gonna let you go because I don't like I
don't want to ever do long ago that I
love this I could go this forever can
you just play the French version the the
sure look look right I know I didn't try
now you pronounce show long but it's
show work
that's a gag that we do the whole time
so when we started doing that one come
up with the idea that when this guy
everybody pronounces the name wrong but
then the girl that he loves she's the
only one that pronounce it right so
that's what we did show look and then
every time somebody say the very first
time did this by the way this gag the
actress so I come up with these things
the actors never know what's gonna
happen and the very first time we did it
the line was just like something like
danielle panabaker okay Sherlock and and
then that's it but I corrected her while
the camera was running I'm like she's
like so sure like I'm like look she's
like look look Sherlock show look look
look look look when you know me I can do
that all day that gag doesn't get
rolling it's funny funny funny that
really not funny humor I love that and
so that became anytime anyone while the
camera was running why the camera wasn't
running said that character's name I
would correct them so there you go I've
done that for your patron I love that
they alright so here it is this is just
some questions from patrons there's just
a couple questions Spitfire so you
answer them quickly we just do it here
we go shit-talking samantha am do you
prefer playing a good version of
harrison wells or an evil version of
course evil of course yeah I like
playing although Lex I had to play good
for quite a while until I finally got
the flip out and that was really fun
marks a could we hit and then I got to
talk like this a lot Martha hey could we
hear about your time on bang bang you're
dead always thought it was underrated
and sadly the movie only becomes more
relevant so that's that's that's not
Spitfire that's basically like another
but as quickly as I can do you can't do
a Spitfire thing about gun violence yeah
yeah Mork bad my book it's bad know that
that thing was a good one else you know
things that you're like rarely do you
feel like you're ever contributing to
society you know that was one of those
jobs where it was like okay you know the
William actually who wrote the rota
to play and then they made the movie of
it their intent was to get this in the
school curriculum and not make any money
off this thing ever and essentially it's
told from the perspective of children
who've lost their lives in school
shootings and what they what they've
given up and what they what they don't
have anymore it's heartbreaking
excuse me it's so it's important I'm not
gonna be able to spit fire a good answer
for this except that sometimes you're so
for stuff to do something you think is
worthy and for those people that don't
know
go read bang bang you're dead or go look
up bang bang you're dead or watch bang
bang you're dead because like like this
person said it's sadly so much part of
the dialogue these days and we so wish
it was it wasn't hopefully anybody that
could look at this can see why we feel
of what we do Robert B can you recall a
memory of one of the hardest days you've
had working on the flash set could you
not just like yeah I can't do I can't
finish this about exhausted I'm not my
mind great so when one of characters I
play Harry wells is running with his
rifle through the woods and being chased
by a giant gorilla grodd I had been up
all that night vomiting the whole family
was sick with the stomach flu and after
like throwing up from 4 or 5 a.m. at a
6:00 a.m. pick up is like I can't go
into work and he's like it's raining
it's pouring rain in Vancouver in
Stanley Park and is 185 people with him
you know you're going and so I went and
you can literally see in the dailies God
and then I run behind the trading floor
whoa I was diving over logs and then
like cut
there you go Robert Lisa the multiple
personalities slash versions of Wells is
my favorite character in the flash okay
that kind of made sense what has it been
like portraying all the personalities
and your favorite version of Wells is
so there's a there's a char Wells and
he's kind of like you know and you know
who owned Wilson he's he's kind of like
that he loves you man you're amazing
she's so fast bro so that guy's great
and then there's Harry who hates
everybody anti-social heart of gold
that's funny - oh no he's great the
sunny well actually all I'm doing I'm
unbelievable this house was also good
but kind of you know he's German but and
so there's a whole bunch of them and
there's no favorite you know the person
that I'm the reason I'm there is the guy
that wears the yellow suit so that's my
favorite thing to do play the
reverse-flash and then after that when
we started doing I think there's 19
versions of wealth which is shameless to
say but and this is the line that I've
used but it really is true the guy that
I'm doing that day the Aussie Wells
oh yeah overall pictural you know
whatever doesn't matter it's sunny well
so you don't the guys that I'm doing
that things the guy that I love doing
Lianne P have you ever taken up any new
hobbies now with the quarantine ukulele
really yeah that's cool it's conquerable
pick up the ukulele folks Emily yes who
would be the one actor you'd love to
work with that you have it like that
Michael Ian Black
hang on right what's the perfect timing
so I emailed him last night I said if
you want to say something oh no see hi
Tom Michael Ian Black here with a quick
shout-out to one of my dear friends Tom
Cavanaugh free Canada
that's a he's got this great brother
that he does so we do a podcast together
are on dunno yeah yeah Tom and Mikey eat
chips right yeah Mikey Tom it's not
exact thanks mate yeah which became this
is thing you loved you know him his
favorite part of dude we did a
television show together yeah lunch he
loved doing lunch we like what
other thing we're like how can we work
together again like you know it's so
hard doing like well we can gather and
do what we always did and just record it
and then we get to be together so that
was a whole thing until his runner on
this podcast is that he just he's
convinced that I play the flash and I
refuse to correct him sake how's it like
doing the flash it's great
he he as you know genius our first I
think he's our first link you would me
yeah that's that's where we met cheers
to Michael Ian Black
funny ass man look him up you know him
you'll be like woohoo
then look him up and you've seen him in
everything he's a genius I love I love
the guy Rachel rakin ragin I'm Esther
and a mum when you're playing a
character who is so far removed from who
you fundamentally are you look for
inspiration and others who behave this
way or do you try to empathize and find
something in them you can relate to so I
we've all got like rage and anger and
all the emotions you need to play any
kind of character we go goodness weak so
he just like you tap into you tap into
that I love you know love that stuff ya
know yeah yeah we do Judy I could answer
this question if Tom doesn't want to
because I I can guess it do you have any
input into the different versions of
Harrison wells it feels like they let
you do whatever you want and I love it
that is it and you know what if he was
like yeah he was like what it's like we
were pushing the Sherlock thing and
there's almost like but what if he's
French
and he's like like what would that be
like is like it would be like this
you're gonna be indulgent but you're not
gonna you're trying to help the show you
know not hurt the shows I think that
yeah man look I love this man I haven't
seen you in so so long but you you're so
easy to talk to and you're so insightful
and the stories are just impactful and
you're just such a good guy and I know
that you're doing so well with the flash
and you deserve it I love seeing the
good guys win and you know I hope maybe
maybe you could promise me at the end
maybe end of next season you'll come
back and talk about stuff
I'll talk to you anytime seriously I got
the in Black's backyard
fantastic you and I thank you for those
kind of like I sometimes I think you and
I we don't complement well it's very
nice to do say that and I appreciate it
I appreciate you all talk to any time my
friend well you guys heard that Tom
Cavanaugh thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you that's something we say
I say I appreciate and your mug maybe
when I mug they're really cool mom yes
they're good mugs yes there it is look
at that so it says thank you for
allowing to be inside of you see that's
a nice little mug I'll send you one good
size right good mug one of your kids is
gonna go what is this dad thank you for
allowing to be inside he what the hell
is it it's some podcast I did I promise
this guys do this podcast is gonna talk
it out did I love you buddy thanks so
much for coming on and good luck with
everything and be safe and healthy and
happy all right buddy there you have it
great guy right really good dude and you
know I like when people are so
forthcoming and open and it's not always
easy it's not easy to get guests to it's
it's hard I do all of them on my own I
get every guest that you've heard is 90
90 99 percent is because I just call
someone you know so-and-so and you know
I think they're skeptical usually and
then they do it and they like it which
makes me feel good because I I want you
to enjoy the show I want people to that
are my guests to enjoy the show that's
why I've had Dane Cook a few times and
McNamara and Stephen Amell and Tom
Welling and Zach Levi and you know it's
it's nice and I and I try to just I try
to it's not that I try to make my show
different
I just don't listen to other podcast not
because I just don't want to be
influenced in a certain way I just want
to do what I do and if people like it
they like it I just want to talk to
people openly candidly as you know and
thanks again to my sponsors
really great stuff fair harbor and feels
obviously when the advertisers do well
they like me and they stay onboard these
guys have a lot of quality stuff so you
might want to check out fields helps me
sleep that CBD stuff in fair harbor I
wear these shorts I'm wearing and now I
mean every day I don't know how many
times I have to tell you all right
here's the folks that really support the
podcast there there's some of them and
they do in a major way and I wouldn't do
it or wouldn't be able to do it without
you guys so thank you a million times
Nancy D Mary bee Leah s Trisha F CeraVe
Yukiko Jill O'Brien H Lauren Genie kopi
Barry L although I always say that but
it's Barry I isn't it sue me Barry come
on Barry you're the only Barry can I
just say Barry
Angelina Gigli Jerry would Kevin or
Emily Kay Bob be Robert B Jason W
Kristin K Amelia Oh Allison L Jason D
Raj Raj he's a patron on both patrons I
have the hora one too many of these
folks are Joshua D Emily SC JP Samantha
M Hamza be Jennifer be Stacey be carly t
Reem Jennifer s Janelle be Tabitha see
Kimberly Melissa see Mikey Jake M
Marissa n on the enamel Jack Slater
Judit d R Amira Beth be Chris F Sarah F
Chad W Lee Anne P Darla almost done
Darla w Jackie peek Rodrigo
raishin see ray a Maya P Meg indeed
Demario Jennifer see Maddie s Tiffany L
Kendrick F Ashley E Kelly W Margie and
Sigourney P I Tom T Matt W and Belinda
and so there you go there the patrons
thanks again please tell everybody to
subscribe and here's a little fan letter
on I'll leave with you
and I thought this was kind of sweet
they're always sweet and look they had
they had a picture there
you almost make sure the person that I
met at a convention all right this is
from rosemary I never listen to podcast
before until the beginning of last year
I kept seeing a Michaels social media
pages about it and I finally had a day
to check it out and I was hooked his
podcast has helped me get through a
really tough time especially since I was
an abusive relationship and some of the
guests have gone through the same thing
made me feel better knowing that I'm not
the only one who's been in that
situation - I don't like even talking
about it either because of how emotional
it is especially for me god I'm crying
too while I'm writing this email don't
cry
besides that I can also relate to
Michael especially when he talked about
losing his grandpa on Thanksgiving last
year - and it goes on I just wanted to
share some of that obviously she's she's
been through a lot
rosemary or with you it's all how we we
deal with it isn't it it's all how the
people around us rise to the occasion
and that's when you really know who your
friends are the people that are always
trying to get into your life and stay in
your life more importantly stay in your
life I just think you were trying to get
into your life that's kind of weird if
you don't know that right but rosemary
there's a lot of love I give you a lot
of love you know and um again I'm not a
physician so I just try to speak from
the heart and talk to my guests and
hopefully you got you obviously got
something out of it and that means the
world so thank you everyone for
listening I hope you have a great week
so many great guests coming up Kevin
Conroy down the road you know that man
Justice League Unlimited
so stick around and keep looking we also
have you know I might just interview the
Justice League Unlimited the whole cast
might happen also reminder make sure you
go to youtube and subscribe on the
inside of you
podcasts on YouTube trying to get those
listens up and those views and you get
to watch it and so that's a lot of fun
so there you go
so hey thank you thanks to my producer
Bryce it was so fun to work with and
easy to work with and really helps me
out I'm a lone man I don't have a wife
or anything and Ryan who does all the
edits he's fantastic
and I miss him all right love you guys
remember the patrons inside of patreon
just go to patreon.com/scishow is mom
and also on patreon aware of all the
good horror movies gone with Jon Heder
and myself talking about horror movies
and it's a lot of fun the line inside of
you online store my favorite charities
don't forget those we just rated raised
a bundle of money for the Ronald
McDonald House thank you Tom Welling
Thank You Kristin Kreuk thank you amazed
thank you Amy Mallon I love that we made
so much money for them and families
still need food and support I just
donated at dinner to them last week so
it's nice and I hope food on foot org
helping the homeless
that's organization out there so thank
you echoes of Hope animal rescue mission
for saving animals hugs and kisses my
uncle Warren has a wonderful foundation
you can also listen to him if you want
to listen and he has a pin the pet show
tell my Sencha and he's fantastic heart
a gold man heart of gold he loved to
look just on an island with animals you
know I'm sure there's a lot of you out
there there's my warriors vest from the
movie over there you can't see it maybe
in the wide shot thank you for the gifts
too you know I get gifts and things I
have the left on Laurel embroidered
thing over there people send me some
cool stuff and patrons your merch boxes
are on the way
way every four months they get a big box
for me so all that stuff I think that's
about it
all right
[Music]